so we hated South Koreans Americans we
didn't know the particip government said
that and we also hated anti-socialism
person anti-socialism countries so that
is opposed to my educations when I was
born so that's why we played all this is
World Games with my friends so that is
growing of brain worship brain worship
and we believed always what government
said that
but the early 1990s they stopped our
rice and then they said to us it is
America problems because we wanted to
buy food in outside the country but
America sanctions to us and then people
died of starvations and we saw many dead
bodies in Street you know train stations
and every day we woke up we heard that
which neighbors died of starvation